say good morning John good morning John
good morning John in unison hahaha did
make a video but for all of you
punishment crazy people all of those
comments that you suggested for me in
John's last video they could very easily
be applied to John who has at least one
outstanding punishment and has no right
to call me out before I even fail at
making a video however there was a very
good punishment suggestion that kind of
only works for me which is that I have
to drive to Canada only a two liter of
Mountain Dew a loaf of bread peanut
butter and $14 that might be funny
enough that I just want to do it without
the punishment thing I also don't want
to be blacklisted from candidate for the
rest of my life maybe right here for
John would be a he'd do a livestream of
him watching The Twilight movies stuff
like a full day of torture but I'm
making a video right now and I haven't
broken the rules in a long time and I'm
gonna keep that streak coming Anaheim at
VidCon obviously of course people
watching this most of you are not going
to be here and so I always feel really
bad if I'm not able to make a video
during VidCon because I'm letting you
down one way you can't come to the
conference so and then I let you down
another way to that's just not right but
the same time I can't spin this video
talking about VidCon because that would
just be sad for you and I can't be like
oh look I got John's past and here's the
program Oh be so jealous it's a really
big book I can't do that to you okay I
just did it to you
I apologize instead of talking about
VidCon as a thing I can talk about what
VidCon is about which is online video
and you know we're do this thing all the
time but we've just done a lot of
discussion about what this thing
actually is what it means I wanted to
talk about it on the main stage of
VidCon but as an example of how hard it
is to get on the main stage at VidCon
this is my conference and I was not able
to get a long enough slot to actually
give a talk about it and I did write one
I don't have time to do it all right now
the piece of what I wrote that is most
interesting to me is that this it's easy
to call this like a revolution in
entertainment and media revolution I
mean really it actually feels like this
is a natural thing now in this world of
infinite options for entertainment like
we get what we want we can watch any
entertaining video it'll take absolutely
no time to on the daily what or whatever
and find something entertaining
instead a lot of us aren't going for
that we're not going for the most
entertaining viral video of the day
going for the people who we we connect
with and we'd like and we enjoy because
of that they make really entertaining
videos but I'm watching in a sense
because I have just grown to really like
their character and the traditional
sense of the word character not that
they are a character that they're
playing but they are character it's
really interesting to me and it's not
technological that's natural that's how
we connect with people as before I think
that the way that we were being
entertained was really artificial and
even with things like the Lizzie Bennet
diaries where these are people playing
characters really wanted to explore
whether or not you can actually have
that connection with a fictional
character it's an experiment it's been a
fairly successful experiment - and it's
so interesting to me at the root of it I
think what's happened is that we're
breaking down all the walls in media and
communication and entertainment and now
we're left with is people who are
building what we had before rants and
juggling and skits and singing like
these aren't new things we've had them
forever I think what that means is that
people created this artificial kind of
of relationship between you know us and
celebrities division between creators
and consumers of creations that barrier
isn't there anymore and that's why I'm
excited about online video and yet why I
had to create VidCon but if it come for
me as a small part of that the big part
of that is this and then I get to be a
part of it and that's so do you it's
very cool to me and thanks John
I will see you momentarily
I very nearly forgot to mentor the most
important product launched at VidCon
John and Sarah play Wii tennis it's
funny and you should go watch it on Hank
games bye